The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lesson today, hopefully,
will serve two purposes.
On the one hand, we will
give a nice application
of the chain rule.
Now that we've had
two units devoted
to working with
the chain rule, I
thought you might
enjoy seeing how
it's used in places
which aren't quite that
obvious-- places that we
wouldn't expect to be used,
at least.
And secondly, I
would like to pick
as my application
one which comes up
in many, many
different contexts.
And without further ado, the
topic I want to cover today
is called "Integrals
Involving Parameters".
Now, that sounds
like a big mouthful.
Let me motivate that for you,
first of all, physically,
and then in term of a couple
of geometric examples.
You all know from
past experience
my great ability with
physical applications,
so I won't even try to find
anything profound here.
Let me just take a
pseudo-example, pointing out
what type of situation
we're trying to deal with
and leaving it to
your own backgrounds
to see places where the same
principle could have been
applied, but hopefully in a
more practical, meaningful way
for you.
Imagine for example,
that we have
a platform that we're looking
along in the x direction.
And we've punched holes
in this platform, say,
and liquid is trickling
through these various holes.
The holes are all on a
horizontal line this way.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to focus our attention
on a particular particle
of the liquid, and we're
going to watch it as it falls.
And what we would
like to do is find
how far that particle fell,
say, during the first second
of its flight.
Obviously, from a
calculus point of view,
the first thing we have to do is
know what the velocity function
is, because ultimately, we would
like to integrate the velocity.
Now, notice that we
would expect the velocity
to be depending on time.
If this were a freely
falling situation,
we'd expect the usual
gravitational type situation.
Or, whatever the
situation happened to be,
we would expect on the
one hand that the velocity
does depend on of time.
On the other hand, because of
how the streams are flowing--
in other words, we
don't know what's
happening above here
that's causing the water
to shoot out-- we don't know
what the initial velocity
is coming out of each of
these holes in the sense
that a different
opening may give rise
to a different velocity
of stream coming out.
All I'm trying to
bring out here is
that as we try to
focus our attention
on a particular opening,
we find that the velocity
of the particle that will follow
it during that first second
is a function both of its
position x-- in other words,
x sub 0 in this case, because
we're focusing at x equals x_0
and the time t as
t goes from 0 to 1.
And we then simply
integrate along
the vertical direction here.
We find y as a function of x_0
from 0 to 1-- v of x_0, t, dt.
Once we're through
integrating, you
see-- notice that
the integration
is with respect to t.
So when we're
through integrating,
this being a definite
integral, t no longer appears.
We have a function of
x_0 alone, saying nothing
more than the distance
that the particle falls
during the first
second is a function
of the position of the
opening along the line here.
Now, at any rate, the
practical application
is not so much writing
down this equation
as the inverse is the case.
Namely, in many
practical applications,
we are given this
particular integral.
And for some reason
or other, want
to determine what v itself is.
In other words, we often want
to find the derivative given
the integral.
All right.
Let's just let it go at
that for the time being.
The important point is
that I want you to see
an example of an integral.
Let me just write this
here in more abstract form.
It appears to be a
definite integral, a to b.
The function inside
the integrand
is apparently a function of
two variables, x and y-- say,
in this case x_0 and t.
One of the variables is a
variable of integration--
in this case, y-- and
the other variable
is being treated as a constant.
And that's where the
word parameter comes in.
x is a parameter, meaning a
variable constant, in the sense
that, for this
particular problem,
x is chosen to be in some
domain and remains fixed.
In other words, this
is some function
of x when we're
all through here.
All right?
As a geometric example, imagine
the following situation.
We have a surface
w equals f of x, y.
We take the plane x equals
x_0 and intersect this surface
with that particular plane.
We get a curve, you see.
Now, we look at that
curve corresponding
to two points, P and Q,
where P and Q are determined
by the y values a and b.
In other words, P
corresponds to y equals a.
Q corresponds to y equals b.
And now, a very natural
question that might come up
is that we would
like to find the area
of this particular plane
region, in other words, the area
of this slice between P and Q.
Now, you know, the first thing
I hope that you'll notice
is that because this
shape of the surface
can be in many different
ways, the particular cross
section that we get does
depend on the choice of x_0.
Different slices--
different planes x equal x_0
will give us different
curves of intersection.
The point is that once we have
the curve intersection-- see,
x is being treated
as the parameter--
this particular curve is
given by what equation?
f is a function of x_0 and y.
See, x equals x_0 for
every point on this curve.
And so the area of the region
R is the integral from a
to b, f of x_0, y, dy.
And the question that
very often comes up
is, how do you find the
derivative of A sub R
with respect to x_0,
noticing, you see,
that A sub R is a
function of x_0 alone,
the y dropping out
between the limits a and b
when we perform the
operation of integration.
A third place that this
type of situation occurs
is in solving certain
differential equations.
For example, suppose we're
given a particular curve
and that that curve determines
a region R between the lines
x equal a and x equal b.
Suppose all we know
about the curve
is its slope at any point.
We know that its
slope at any point
is given by dy/dx, or
some function of x and y,
which we don't necessarily
have to go into right now.
And let's suppose, for
the sake of argument,
that we solve this first-order
differential equation.
What we'll find,
if we're lucky, is
that y is some function of
x and an arbitrary constant.
Remember, once you have one
solution to a differential
equation, you have
an infinite family
in terms of a one-parameter
solution to a differential
equation.
In other words, in finding
the area of the region
R in this case,
there are many curves
that satisfy this particular
differential equation.
Until we know what
specific points are
being referred to over here, the
best we know for sure is what?
That these endpoints
are a and b,
that the integrand
is f of x comma c,
and we're integrating that
with respect to x from a to b.
I Freudianly put a
c in here, because I
think what I was
trying to emphasize
for you is that when
you look at this thing,
observe that this integral
is a function of c alone.
Namely, when you
integrate this thing,
you integrate it
with respect to x.
The x drops out.
All you have left here is a c.
A sub R, then, is
a function of c.
And in many cases,
what we would like
to do is see how fast the area
changes as a function of c.
In other words, how
do we change the area
as a function of changing
the arbitrary constant c?
And I have enough exercises
in the assignment to give you
concrete drill on this.
All I'm trying to give
you here is an overview
of the entire topic.
And the reason I want to
give you this overview
is that it's hinted
at in the textbook,
but this topic is
not covered there.
In fact, the reason
that I had you
read that particular section of
the textbook before the lecture
this time-- you
notice that usually we
start with the lecture.
This time I had you
read the textbook first,
because the way the
textbook covered
this topic is
essentially nothing
more than the way we
tackled a different problem
last semester.
And I want you to see that the
problem done in the Thomas text
is not a new problem-- it's
one that we've done before--
but that with the tools
that we now have available,
we could've tackled a
more significant problem.
And that's the one I'm
electing to do here
and what I want to show you the
key steps on, because they're
not in the text.
But I will leave the
reinforcement for the exercise.
At any rate, hopefully
now, when you
see an integral of this type,
it will not bother you too much.
In other words,
don't worry about
how do you integrate a function
of two independent variables?
When you see
something like this,
it means that there is some
implicitly implied domain
for x.
In other words, we have
some function of x.
Let's say the domain
of g might very well
be, say, all x's between
two values, say c and d.
But who cares about
that right now?
The important point
is that g is defined
on a certain set of values x.
And what it says is to compute
the output of the g machine.
For the given x, you fix that
x and integrate f of x comma y
dy between a and b.
Notice, you see,
during the integration,
x is being treated
as a constant,
so that for all
intents and purposes,
this is an ordinary integral.
But because x isn't a bona
fide constant, meaning what?
It's a constant only in
the sense that once chosen,
it remains fixed for this
particular integration.
Different values of x will give
me different integrals here.
And consequently, a very
natural question that comes up
is how does my function
g-- which depends on x--
how does that vary as x varies?
In other words, the key
question is simply this.
First of all, given g
defined this way, one,
does g prime even exist?
Does dg/dx exist?
And two, if it does
exist, what is it?
In other words, the
question that we're raising
is, if we can find
g prime of x, how
do we do it in terms of
looking at the right-hand side?
And let me not try to
guess the answer here.
The answer does turn out to be,
in this particular case, one
that you might have guessed.
But I prefer to show you that we
don't have to guess, point one.
Point two, if you do guess,
you won't always be that lucky.
That's my finale
for today's lecture.
But let me see if I can survive
to get to the finale first.
Let me see how we'll
tackle a problem like this.
First of all, to see if g
prime exists at some value x_0,
what we have to do is-- way
back to the very beginning
of Part 1-- the
same old definition
for an ordinary derivative.
We have to compute the
limit of g of x sub 0 plus h
minus g of x sub
0 over h, taking
the limit as h approaches 0.
Notice what the
g machine does...
What the g machine does is
it feeds x into the integrand
here and integrates this with
respect to y from a to b.
So if the input of my g
machine is x_0 plus h, that
means that the x is replaced by
x_0 plus h here. g of x_0 plus
h is simply integral from a to
b f of x_0 plus h comma y dy.
Similarly, g of x_0 is integral
from a to b f of x_0, y, dy.
I now want to form
this difference.
And noticing-- again,
this is all calculus
of a single variable--
that the difference of two
definite integrals is
the definite integral
of the difference,
I can conclude
that g of x_0 plus
h minus g of x_0
is simply this single
integral over here.
Now, my next step in
determining g prime of x_0
is I must divide this by h.
Notice, by the way, that h is
an arbitrary increment, but once
chosen, remains fixed.
Notice that h is
a constant as far
as this integration
is concerned.
Consequently, to
divide by h, it is
permissible to bring the
h inside the integrand.
In other words, technically
speaking, the h should be here,
but since h is a constant
with respect to y,
the integral can have
the h brought in.
Why do I want to
bring the h in here?
Let me again telegraph
what I'm leading up to.
Obviously, when I'm
going to compute g prime,
my next step is to
take the limit of this
as h approaches 0.
With h in here, I
look at this and what
I hope is that by
this amount of time,
at least the following
minimum amount of material
has rubbed off on you
in a second nature way:
that if I look at this
expression in brackets
as h approaches 0,
this is precisely
the definition of what we
mean by the partial of f
of x, y with respect to
x evaluated at (x_0, y).
See, this is what?
The change in f-- see,
y is held constant.
We're taking this over a
change from x_0 to x_0 plus h
and dividing by h.
This is a partial of
f with respect to x.
That's why I want to
bring the h inside.
So now, I say, OK, g prime
of x_0, by definition,
is this limit.
I now want to take the
limit of this expression.
And by the way, notice
what I'd love to do now
is to jump right in
here and say, aha,
this is just the partial
of f with respect
to x evaluated at (x_0, y_0).
But the thing I would like
you to notice-- and again,
going back to Part 1 of our
course, one of the big things
that we talked about, under the
heading of uniform convergence,
that it is a very
dangerous thing in general
to interchange the order
of limit and integration.
This says what?
First perform the integration,
and then take the limit.
What we would like to be able
to do is first take the limit
and then integrate the result.
Now, we did see that, provided
the integrand was continuous,
these operations
were permissible.
But we'll talk about
that a little later.
For the time being,
let's simply summarize
by saying if the limit operation
and the integration operation
can be interchanged, then
the derivative-- see,
this thing here is what?
This is my g of x
The derivative of g
of x with respect
to x has the very
delightful form that,
essentially, all I have to do
is take the
derivative operation,
come inside the
integrand, and replace
the derivative with respect
to x by the partial derivative
with respect to x.
In other words, the derivative
of the integral from a
to b, f of x, y, dy
is the integral from a
to b, the partial
of f with respect
to x dy-- provided, of
course, that the limit
and the integration
are interchangeable.
In particular, this
will be true if f and f
sub x exist and are continuous.
And to straighten out
the range and the domain
and what have you
once and for all,
notice that y is allowed
to exist between a and b.
We've said that x
is going to exist
on some domain between c and d.
Notice that saying
that y is between a
and b and x is between
c and d geometrically
says that f is defined
on a rectangle.
See?
OK.
And then what we're saying
is, under these conditions,
to integrate an integral
with a parameter,
with respect to that
parameter, all we have to do
is come inside the integral
sign and differentiate-- take
the partial derivative--
with respect
to what is being used
as the parameter.
In this case, it's x,
which is the parameter.
Now, the only danger with
this particular thing--
and by the way, notice,
not only is there a danger
here that I'm going to mention.
The danger is this looks
so easy, you may be saying,
why did he do it the hard way?
Why didn't he just tell us this
was the right way of doing it?
And the point is it just happens
to be one of those coincidences
where the rigorous way
yields a logical answer which
is consistent with what is
probably our intuitive guess.
But it's not always
going to happen that way.
And the example that
I have in mind now
goes back to what we were
talking about the beginning
of the lecture.
Namely, I wanted to give you an
application of the chain rule.
And here's where that
application comes in.
I now call this-- I don't
know what to call it.
So let's just call it variable
limits of integration.
Same problem as before--
it's going to cause the chain
rule to come in now.
The only difference
is going to be--
and that's just a forewarning.
You don't have to
know that right now.
I'm going to have the
same problem as before.
What did I have before?
I had that g(x) of
x was integral f
of x, y, dy between the
two constants a and b.
Now, I'm going to let my
constants of integration
also depend on the parameter.
See, all the constants
of integration
have to be are constants
as far as y is concerned.
What I'm saying is what
makes this problem differ
from the previous one is suppose
that it happens that instead
of being given a nice
rectangle to play around with,
I'm given a couple of curves
like this in the xy-plane.
See, this would be a of x.
This would be y equals b of x.
See, what I'm saying now is
that not only does the integrand
depend on what
value of x I pick,
but the limits of
integration as I'm
finding a cross-sectional
area of a surface, you see.
The limits of the
integral themselves
depend on the choice
of x-- constant,
as far as y is concerned,
but depend on x.
You see, now, what happens
is that my parameter appears
in the limits as well as
just in the integrand.
And now, you see, also
what this means is
if I try the previous
approach of computing g of x
plus delta x, et
cetera, I'm in trouble,
because the only way I
can combine two integrals
and put them under
the same integral sign
is if they're between the
same limits of integration.
Notice here, for
example, that if I
replace x by x plus delta x, I
not only change the integrand,
but notice that the
limits become what?
a of x plus delta x, b of x plus
delta x, and those in general,
unless a and b happen to be
constants, will vary with x.
In fact, let's look
at it this way.
This is the problem we should
have started with in the sense
that constant limits
of integration
are a special case of this.
At any rate, what
I wanted to show
you was that this
particular problem
can be handled very nicely
in terms of the chain rule.
Namely, what we do here is we
observe that, first of all,
y is not really a variable here.
It's integrated out.
So what we think
of is: let's think
of x as being some variable u.
Let's think of b of x as
being some variable v. Let's
write down the function of
three independent variables u,
v, and x.
OK.
What will that function be?
Let u, v, and x be arbitrary,
independent variables.
Look at the integral from
u to v, f of x, y, dy.
This is obviously
dependent upon u.
It's dependent upon v.
And it's dependent upon x.
The place that the chain
rule comes in is that
in our particular problem,
u and v cannot be arbitrary,
but rather u must be that
particular function a of x,
and v must be the
particular function b of x.
Consequently g of
x is simply what?
It's h of u, v, x, where u
is a of x and v is b of x.
Consequently, to
find g prime of x,
what we want is h prime
of x, and to find h prime
as a function of x.
See the chain rule here?
u can be expressed
in terms of x.
v can be expressed
Obviously, x is already
expressed in terms of x.
So this is really implicitly
a function of x alone.
So by the chain rule, what
I'd like to be able to do
is to combine these three
pieces of information to find h
prime of x.
And remember how the
chain rule works.
Now, I'm not going to
beat that to death.
We've just had
two units on that.
Let's just say it
rather quickly.
g prime of x is the
partial of h with respect
to u times u prime of
x plus the partial of h
with respectively
to v times v prime
of x times the partial
of h with respect
to x times x prime of x,
which, of course, is just 1.
In other words,
writing this thing out,
g prime of x is simply this.
What is the partial of
h with respect to u?
Let's come back here for a
second and remember what h is.
h is this integral.
I want to take the partial
of that with respect to u.
That means I have
to investigate this.
Now, here's the
interesting point.
Whereas u, v, and x are
independent variables,
what does it mean when
you say you're taking
the partial with respect to u?
It means that you're treating
v and x as constants.
Now, if v and x are being
treated as constants,
what I have is simply what?
I'm taking a
derivative with respect
to a variable, where the only
place the variable appears
is as the lower limit
of the integrand.
In other words, I claim
that that's nothing
more than minus f of x comma u.
That I go inside the
integrand-- in other words,
I differentiate the
integral-- that leaves me
just the integrand--
and replace the variable
by the variable of
integration u here.
And because it's the lower
limit, I put in the minus sign.
Now, why did I go
through that very fast?
That's why I had you read
this assignment first.
Notice that the
assignment in the textbook
does not touch what
I'm talking about,
but rather seems to review
that topic that we covered
under Part 1--
that if you wanted
to take an ordinary
derivative with respect
to u, integral from
u to a, g of y dy,
the answer would
just be minus g of u.
And that's exactly
what I did in here.
I treated v and x
as constants here.
In other words, the only
variable in here was u.
That will be emphasized
again in the exercises.
In a similar way, the partial
of h with respect to v
means this thing.
Notice now that u is being
treated as a constant.
x is being treated
as a constant.
To differentiate
this, my variable
appears only as an upper
limit on the integrand.
That means I come inside
the integral sign,
replace the integral by
just the function itself,
replacing what?
The variable by the
limit of-- replacing
y-- that's the only
variables of integration--
by the upper limit v.
In other words, this
is f of x comma v. All right?
And finally, the partial
of h with respect to x
is this integral here.
Notice now that u and v are
being treated as constants.
With u and v being
treated as constants,
that's the special case that
we started our lecture with,
namely, to differentiate with
respect to a parameter when
the parameter appears only
as part of the integrand.
So how do we do that?
We come inside.
This is the integral
from u to v,
the partial of f with
respect to x, dy.
Putting the whole thing
together-- recalling,
among other things, that
du/dx, since u is a of x,
is just a prime of x,
and that dv/dx is b prime
of x-- what this
says-- and again,
I want you to see the beauty
of the chain rule here,
because at least to
my way of thinking,
I don't see anything at all
intuitive about the result I'm
going to show you.
And that is, as soon as you
make the limits of integration
variable, to differentiate
an integral involving
a parameter-- you see, again,
what's the parameter here? x.
We integrate it
with respect to y.
This is a constant as
far as y is concerned.
See, intuitively,
you might say, gee,
all you've got to do is
take the derivative sign,
bring it inside, and this
should be the answer.
See, it's the same
as we did before.
The point is-- and this is
where many serious mistakes are
made in problems involving
integrals of this type--
is that the reason that
our intuitive way happened
to be right in the simpler
case was that these were
constants with respect to x.
Now, they're variables.
Well, it turns out, if you
just wrote this thing down,
you would be wrong.
What is the correction factor?
Again, come back to here.
The correction
factor is this here,
which we've just
started to compute.
Again, just saying it-- if
you wrote this term down
to get the correct answer, you
would have to tack on what?
b prime of x times
f of x comma b of x.
That means what?
You think of a y
as being over here.
For the particular value of
x, you replace y by b of x.
In other words,
you look at f of x
comma y, and every place you
see a y, replace it by b of x.
And then subtract
that from that a prime
of x times f of x comma a of x.
Now again, I suspect
that, for many of you,
it's the first time that
you've seen something
like this, because I
say, it's a topic which
I believe was a natural one
to occur in the textbook,
but for some reason it
doesn't appear there.
Because of the importance
of the concept,
the number of times it appears
in physical applications,
the number of times that
one has to differentiate
with respect to an
integral-- I don't
know the physical applications
well enough to lecture on them,
but it does occur in probability
theory, among other places,
it appears in any subject
involving integral equations
and the like-- that
I wanted to give you
the experience of seeing
what the concept means,
to have you hear me say it.
And then I will
spend the exercises
trying to drive home the
computational know-how so
that you will be able to
do these things, at least
in a mechanical
way, independently
of whether the theory made
that much sense because
of the lack of physical
example motivation
other than what I
did at the beginning.
At any rate, keep
in mind, though,
that in terms of our
present topic, where we're
talking about the
chain rule, this
is a certainly noble application
to show an important place
in the physical world where
knowledge of the chain rule
plays a very important role.
And with that, I might just as
well conclude today's lecture.
And until next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.